I'm here to answer the internet should
you lock a dog out of a room when you're
having sex absolutely I brought my dog
to a hookup because I'm codependent and
she we had sex and then she ran into the
[__] room jumped on the bed and
licked his dick anyway
and I did so
I wasn't invited back let's just let
that one is jerking off to webcam girls
cheating
I mean as someone who hasn't been in a
relationship in 10 years it's hard to
say goodbye I wouldn't think it's
cheating I would think it's just sad but
I don't know I would rather a webcam
girl see it that's getting paid then I
have to see it right
like I don't really want to watch you
jerk off so let alone behind a camera so
if that's what you want to do and that's
where you want to spend your money as
long as we're still going to dinner
is it weird for a guy to prefer Lube
hand jobs over blow jobs absolutely uh
in college my freshman year I was such I
didn't do anything and the first time I
gave a [__] I wear a lot of rings so
unbeknownst to me my nickname became bad
hand drop Hannah
[Laughter]
so I never give hand jobs I'm like I'll
give a [__] like
I'm just lazy
I'm like how am I signal it's a great
thing I mean that [__] Hannah yeah
that's it I would walk the dogs I'd be
like dhh whatever the [__] it was and I
was like what is this the second you
hear that like
would you rather live in a world without
headphones or a world without doors
oh
probably a world without doors honestly
really yeah that's crazy
that's borderline dangerous I'd be able
to close doors if I have to walk if I
have an Aaron to run and I'll have my
headphones and they're not charged that
Aaron is not being done so you just
never do anything if you didn't have
headphones yeah I'm like I guess I can't
do anything today I'm out it's personal
dude you stay over at someone's house
and you wake up and realize you pissed
all over their bed do you sneak out or
tell them I guess I'll just speak from
experience um I don't drink anymore
because I used to have well not that's
not the only reason why I don't drink
anymore but in college there were a
couple times where I like fully pissed
the bed and you just kind of have to own
it yeah like you what do you you can't
be like oh that's your pee
depends on who you're sleeping with yeah
you fall asleep in bed with John
feidelberg you can you can blame him for
the people every single time and I've
fallen asleep with bad girls who
believed it
yeah or they told you they believed it
and then right away the group chat is
blown up
yeah what about like um
you've talked before
in a bottle of water
and put it you like kind of spill it
like you wake up in the morning you
realize repeat the bed you grab an empty
beer can or a water bottle whatever you
just be like oh okay honestly drinking
the water bottle I don't think that far
through yeah
yeah a sociopath and I'm like oh let me
go to the [__] fridge and raid it and
like plants never cry that's crazy
just in case you ever get back in the
game that also works yeah no I went to
rehab that was the solution
would you rather wake up in the middle
of the night to see a massive dude has
broken into your house or to see a ghost
obviously a ghost no question I would
not want to massive dude in my house
even when I know he's like even though
when I know he's probably gonna sleep
over I would prefer him leave you know
what I mean let alone a random guy in my
house a ghost how much is too much for a
height difference in a relationship
I you know what I think Love Has No No
Boundaries oh shut up
love has a boundary yeah I'm not dating
a guy who's six seven because he's gonna
like I said earlier he's gonna die early
and I am not rich enough to afford her
children's lifestyle which I know will
be a lot whatever guy is where you die
yeah would you rather be a pig and be
able to orgasm for 30 minutes absolutely
not that would be so painful or be a
lion and be able to have sex 60 times a
day both sound exhausting
um I would say
I'm like
I'm seven months
um I would say 60 times a day right I
don't know 30 minute orgasm you're like
30 minutes
how do you not have a heart attack from
that yeah right yeah at an old age 30 a
30 minute workout I'm sessions I'd
rather just have good stamina see the
thing about the lion is you can have sex
up to 60 times a day exactly so it's
like today I only had sex four times but
I could go for 60. yeah because if it's
about 56 more in the chamber yeah yeah
what is this lion benching you know I
mean I want that stamina for sure if
there was stats available for every
aspect of your life what's one stat you
would want to see
how much money did I spend on GrubHub I
guess I could just go look at it that's
what I don't want to know yeah exactly I
guess I'd want to know how many times
where I've been ghosted where a guy was
just like
too intimidated you know it was like I
was out of his League that would be a
good stat to know where he was like I
don't know like twice or they were like
negative zones they were like never what
are you talking about
thanks for keeping me in check I
appreciate it uh yeah that's a tough one
I don't know you're like all right this
is hell like no no
how many minutes I was bleeding for I
would like to know
because that means that like I lived a
long life and I did a lot of I
accomplished a lot of [__] I was
bleeding for like years
we're watching answer the internet
please subscribe to the channel comment
below on other celebrities you'd like to
see and make sure you hit the Bell to
get notifications when new episodes come
out